we already made a video
about the most horrific deranged
Creations that came from people doing
some nasty stuff to Clorox in the legend
of zeldate of the Kingdom today we're
going to be taking a look at some of the
most impressive things that people have
made so far some incredible engineering
I have not pre-watched any of these so
that I get to watch them on with you
live this one obviously bit of a
giveaway in the title
um and this immediate thumbnail image
I'm excited to watch
it has like a little cockpit
[Music]
[Laughter]
I did not expect it to like semi-walk
like that
[Music]
really smart the record is killing me
oh my gosh
oh it lost a leg
Still Standing though
that's amazing work very impressive my
best attempt at building a guardian
dude
they gave it the legs and everything
that's so cool
obviously doesn't walk
that is rad I never would have thought
to do that
no way
oh it is on Treads though so maybe it
can move I wonder if like putting
the Drone things on the bottom would
make it start to move of its own accord
because really it's not but that could
just be the timing and on
damn I love that that's so cool the
amazing Zone I Crusher
oh
this is a literal crushing machine
oh my God
the creativity
it's like several lands
foreign
[Laughter]
useful in one place
dude ah okay jumping over to YouTube for
this one
wait wait it's like a Mech
[Music]
it fully is like a Mecca
oh my God
[Music]
that's so elaborate
it's like space dog battles
space talk fights I mean
oh my God
you can do this in The Legend of Zelda
there are so many like even actual Mech
games where people look I just want to
be able to fly around the map
the fact that you can do this in this
game is insane
[Music]
oh oh wait wait they created multiple
forms
[Music]
also this does have some music in the
background I'm probably gonna have to
mute because it's a licensed Zone
unfortunately
[Music]
that is like
unfathomably impressive
somebody on Twitter made a beam rifle
oh my God I feel like I'm just
repeatedly saying oh my God but what
else am I supposed to say
video version
this is it in action
dude I guess most of that's just
aesthetic
like actually functionally not that
complicated
but appearance wise
and yeah I guess you could just carry it
around
okay this one is a multi-stage rocket
that requires
manual operation by using interlocking
log beams
I would like to see it
foreign
[Music]
that's so smart
that one just like destroyed my brain
the fact that somebody
did that I this is like had a profound
effect on me I don't know why this one
just got me so hard that I was like oh
my God a human made this
like sometimes you're like damn mankind
is pretty cool the fact that you can do
this in Zelda and the fact that somebody
thought to do it and made a rocket with
things that actually fall off I want to
watch that again this is
especially because it has no functional
purpose other than
this would be pretty cool right like
it's not to destroy things
dude
I know that this is an insane thing to
say as in response to something that
somebody made on Reddit
but
video games are odd
I'm putting it out there video games are
on I don't care
that's insane
this video is only 15 seconds long and
the caption I don't know if that called
that on Twitter just says
so it better be good
trying to lure them
[Laughter]
it's so unnecessary
oh dude I love stuff like this because
it's just
this person clearly just did this to
make themselves laugh and thus also all
of us love like you don't need to do
that you could kill him with a stick
my rigging experience literally plays
into my tears of the king gameplay out
Treads in-game as well
whoa they made an engine
oh my God
can you imagine
whoa oh that's so cool if we got an
update like a Minecraft style update
that would like allow people to actually
generate power with creations
oh my God
that's so smart
dude that's so sick
okay this one
I guess it's gonna be a dick thing this
has a lot of Engagement
a lot of people have seen this one
[Laughter]
of course they did
but it explodes Mankind in a nutshell to
be honest okay this one's from temporary
underscore process 37 but they do credit
this YouTube video here
and it is a Batmobile I guess
oh it's like a Tumblr
can you
drive it oh my God you can
like can you control what direction it's
going in
I the transformation is so cool
dude
so you know the coolest thing about all
of these
with like a few weeks in
like this game just exists forever now
it's not going anywhere it exists now
this stuff is only going to get cooler
and cooler and cooler and people are
already making stuff that I never would
have even comprehended that we could
make
all right I might make another one of
these like in a few weeks or something
maybe another horrific Creations one I
don't know they're very fun to make
because this was the thing about tears
in the Kingdom that I was like most
excited about more excited about seeing
the fun stuff people made than even
playing it myself in this case I am not
making cool stuff but I can enjoy what
everyone else is making